JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiwicz, and
I'm here with JJ Behrens.
JJ BEHRENS: Hey, nice
to see you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Nice seeing you.
Long time, no see.
JJ BEHRENS: I think
since lunch.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Exactly.
And today, we'll talk about
YouTube for your Business,
which is a webinar that JJ
recently published on YouTube.
So we have a couple of questions
for you, JJ.
You ready?
JJ BEHRENS: I hope so.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, so the
first question is, I watched
this seminar.
It's very interesting, but
I never knew what was
going to come next.
So you cover a lot of ground.
What triggered you to actually
create a seminar that covers
so much ground in 15 minutes?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, considering
you've given this talk like
umpteen billion times,
trying to surprise
you is pretty hard.
I had this idea that I wanted
to start with very
nontechnical examples
and then migrate to
very technical examples.
And all along the way, I want
to show you something, talk
about it, show you how I did
it, and then give you a
take-home message.
And so that's really
where it's at.
And I really kind of did want
to surprise the user.
Because there's so many
different ways
you could use YouTube.
I wanted to keep
them guessing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That
makes sense.
You definitely had
me guessing.
So question about some of the
content that you covered.
I really like the video "New
Dork." It's timeless.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I have
to watch it daily.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Exactly.
I think it definitely put me
in the right state of mind.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I didn't quite
get the part when you
talked about how Grasshopper
benefits from having published
a video on YouTube.
How do people know that hey,
this is Grasshopper, or this
is the product that's
being advertised?
All I see is an awesome artist
and his backup singer equally,
if not more awesome.
And how do I actually make the
connection with Grasshopper?
JJ BEHRENS: She was pretty
awesome, wasn't she?
Yeah, Grasshopper--
well, it works a couple
different ways.
So there's metadata
for the video.
And so the metadata has a
link to grasshopper.com.
And there's also basically ad
placement in the video for
grasshopper.com.
And those two things together
are basically a great way to
spread the message of
grasshopper.com.
And the greatest thing
about this is that
it goes viral, right?
I can't stop watching that
video, because I love watching
that guy sing about random
things and show pictures of
famous people in
the background.
So it's like awesomely
free advertising.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
is the metadata.
Something that they have to pay
for, or how does the user
actually encounter the
link to grasshopper?
JJ BEHRENS: No, it's free.
And when you upload a video to
YouTube, you can pick your own
description and so forth, and
you can embed whatever you
want in the video, to some
degree, of course.
We have rules, but--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the URL to
Grasshopper is basically in
the description, and that's
what drives the referral
[INAUDIBLE].
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
that's right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
OK, great.
Another video that
you showed is the
original skateboards video.
So I was wondering, how are
you skateboarding skills?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, you can't
see it, because
it's below the table.
But I have scars all over
my body, which--
it's not pretty.
So definitely--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Not so good?
JJ BEHRENS: Not so good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what type
of skateboard do you have or
are you planning to buy in the
near future [INAUDIBLE]?
JJ BEHRENS: So I was
a street skater.
I did a little bit of downhill
as a kid, which results in
lots of long scars with
heavy scarring flesh.
But yeah, I suck at
skateboarding.
I was glad to finally discover
programming, because I was
finally good at that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Maybe you should just watch
that video instead.
JJ BEHRENS: I know.
That video makes me want
to buy a skateboard.
I'll tell you that much.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Definitely.
Definitely.
So you talk about YouTube Direct
and how this product,
open source project, it's
great for soliciting
user-generated content.
So the question I have, since
this is a talk about YouTube
for your Business , is suppose
I'm not a developer.
How do I deploy it?
And then how much time
would it take me?
Can you tell me a little more
about what's involved in
actually getting it set
up for business?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so YouTube
Direct is not the easiest
thing to set up.
I mean, if you go through the
instructions, it walks you
through setting up Eclipse.
And as soon as you say Eclipse,
you're going to lose
30% of developers out there.
But we have a session coming up
at Google I/O that somehow
talks about this thing called
YouTube Direct Light.
And I'm just guessing--
I don't know for certain, but
I'm guessing that that Light
means something, and that it
might be easier for people
going forward.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if you are
a developer, what skills
do we need to have in order
to get it all done?
What are all the major pieces
that you need to be familiar
with in order to deploy it?
JJ BEHRENS: So to deploy YouTube
direct, I mean, you
don't actually have to alter
any source code.
You basically--
it's a Java application, and
it uses Google App Engine.
And so you don't actually have
to do any coding to set it up.
It was fairly hard to set up for
people who weren't coders
at all, didn't know how to
do things with clips and
installing the right
applications.
I think it's going to get even
easier in the future, and I
think we're going to get to a
situation where you don't have
to be a developer at all.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I
hear YouTube Direct
is written in Java.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what
do you think about that?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, you know,
there's a lot of people who
really like Java.
That's what I think
about that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's a very
diplomatic answer, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What
happened to you?
JJ BEHRENS: Well,
you know, I--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is it late in
the day, or you didn't have
your caffeine yet, or
what's going on?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, I
am a Python guy
and a Ruby guy, so--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, I
tried to get you going.
JJ BEHRENS: Jeez.
Are we going to go into Emacs
versus vi as well?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Maybe next time.
OK, good.
So sounds like it's really not
that big of a deal, as long as
you have some skills
and you know how
to use the App Engine.
JJ BEHRENS: That's right.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So you talked about coffee
table applications.
So my question is, are these
applications spill-proof?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, that's
a great question.
So I should first start off with
explaining what a coffee
table application is.
So tablets are pretty popular
these days, and 955 Dreams is
a company that has a few
different applications,
including The History of Jazz
and Band of the Day.
And these applications
are just beautiful.
You just want to
play with them.
It's like you pick it up, and
you're like, I want to play
with this thing.
And so there's this idea
that you just put these
applications on a tablet, and
you leave them on your coffee
table, whereas in the past we
used to have art books on your
coffee table.
And people will come over and
visit, start playing with the
application.
And it's just a really
neat experience.
Now, as to whether they're spill
proof, you know, I think
you have an iPad.
We could try it out.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How about
we use your tablet?
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, well,
you know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: If I want to
learn more about these types
of apps, where can I find
more information?
JJ BEHRENS: I'm not
actually sure.
I mean, I guess you could go
check out 955 Dreams' Apps,
and just try them out.
That's the best I could say.
I mean, I really like
Band of the Day.
I think that that's a really
compelling app.
I asked him, how do you
guys come up with
such beautiful apps?
And he says, well,
we go completely
custom from day one.
They decide not to do
native widgets.
They completely build their
UI from scratch.
And he says, that's
what we do to make
things extremely beautiful.
Band of the Day has this
beautiful calendar with the
artwork for the artist
in the background.
And I don't know, those guys
have something I don't have.
Design skills.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
you're pretty stylish.
So you talk about OAuth2.
And I think--
again, this is a talk,
talks about
YouTube for your business.
OAuth2 is something that sounds
a little scary to an
average user.
Why not use username
and passwords?
What's wrong with that?
Can you just ask people to type
in their credentials and
be done with it?
This is how things have been
done for many years, right?
So is it really necessary?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so it turns
out that client login, which
uses a username and password,
has a bunch of different
failure modes.
And because of all those
different failure modes, we've
actually deprecated it.
So the nice thing about OAuth2
is that it allows an
application to do things on
your behalf without you
sharing your username
and password.
So that makes it a lot
more secure world.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is it more
difficult to program?
Say I'm a developer.
I want to use the YouTube API.
And I know a client login.
I know username and passwords.
What do I need to do to actually
integrate OAuth?
JJ BEHRENS: So I think that
there's a couple different
things that are helpful to do.
The first is that we
have really good
documentation on this.
I'm always amazed at how good
Andy is at writing our tech
docs for YouTube.
So he has this one-page thing
that explains OAuth2.
I read that, and I
didn't understand
anything before that.
And I read that, and it all
made sense after that.
We also have an OpenID demo,
which is very related and
shows you all the
different steps.
And you walk through that,
and it explains it.
And also, the client libraries
tend to have samples of how to
do this stuff.
And so when I did my other
webinar based on Ruby on
Rails, I actually took source
code from the client library,
and it walked me through all
the different parts.
And so yeah, there is
some learning curve.
But it's worth it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what does
the Auth stand for in OAuth?
JJ BEHRENS: I could never tell
if it's authentication or
authorization, but I think it's
a little bit of both.
I think it's authorization.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think
it stands for oh, man.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh man, yeah.
And the two.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So you mentioned Google I/O, and
this is where I'm going to
try to get you to leak stuff,
because I know leaking is
something that you never do.
And I always want to get
some more information.
So which feature from the
features that we're going to
be launching at Google I/O for
YouTube, which one gets you
most excited?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, jeez.
Are we talking about most
excited in terms of ones that
I'm going to use, or most
I'm afraid that other people in
the company might not let
us talk about?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Now you're
getting too tricky, I think.
So which ones are you
going to use?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, we have a talk
where we're talking about
the new YouTube Direct Light.
And it talks about soliciting
videos from your users.
And I've seen that talk, of
course, in rehearsal, and I'm
super excited about this.
I think this is going
to be a big deal.
In fact, I would have to say
this is pure dead brilliant.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks.
So for folks that have watched
the YouTube for Your Business,
what are the next steps?
If I want to learn more, I want
to use YouTube for my
business, if I want to
advertise, if I want to build
application developers, where
do I go to find more
information about all the
different places?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so there's a
bunch of different directions
you could go.
This talk kind of straddles the
middle, but once you start
in the middle, you have to walk
in a certain direction.
So if you're a content owner,
and you're doing your own
sitcoms or something like that,
you probably want to go
to youtube.com/partner and
become a content partner.
Now, if you're an application
developer, you want to learn
more about using the
YouTube API.
So you could go to
youtube.com/dev.
Either way, there's going to be
a lot of videos at Google
I/O, and you could watch all
of those different videos.
And we're going to be having
them online after I/O, just in
case you can't make it to I/O.
And I think once you watch all
those different videos, you'll
know where to go next.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Thanks, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, why thank you.
And I'm just so happy that the
interns over there on the
couch stopped making
funny faces.
I was going to crack up in the
middle of the talk, but now
we're almost done.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
I think this is all
the questions
that we have received.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, thanks a lot,
guys, for watching.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
And for those of you that will
see us at Google I/O, we
really appreciate
your feedback.
And talk to you later.